Tony we just covered some important
financial resolutions what other ways
can we set ourselves up for a good start
to 2020 well Anthony the new year is
also a good time to take some
resolutions for healthy tech use in fact
if you're watching this on a smartphone
right now I advise you to sit back chin
up watch those shoulders and about those
smartphones about 80% of Americans now
own a smartphone that is up from 35% as
recently as 2011 and the average
American adult now spends more than 3
hours a day on those phones a lot of
time Sharon Profis is executive editor
and director of content for our partners
at C net and she joins us now for some
healthy tips on tech yes are there
healthy resolutions you can make on tap
there are yes we spend way too much time
on our smartphone so one of the best
things you can do this year is spend
less time and how do we do that it
starts really by tricking your brain
into being a little less addicted to
this device that is actually designed to
hit that dopamine and make us want to
reach for it over and over again so one
of my favorite tricks if this is the
only thing you do I recommend you do it
is to make your phone go grayscale what
does that mean it means that many apps
and even the design work phone it's
designed to reel us in with beautiful
colors so if you make your phone go
grayscale it'll be a little bit less
enticing and you can do that using the
settings in either your Android or your
iPhone very helpful the other thing I
hate about my smartphone is I get a lot
of spam calls on there can I block those
somehow yeah so one in every six
Americans get the spam call spam texting
is on the rise and spam in general went
up seven percent last year so now many
carriers and even phone makers are
noticing this and trying to help
consumers block it the iPhone and
Samsung phones as well as Google devices
have built-in settings that let you
automatically silence spam calls another
app you can use is called hi-yah
and it'll filter out spam calls and let
you know what businesses are calling but
one of my favorite tips because honestly
the tech spam is the most annoying for
me is that you can forward spam text
messages to spam espy a.m. and the
carriers will take notice and start to
block those callers I like that I feel
my own tech use is taking an effect here
in this segment as I lean oh yeah
it slowly hunch forward but we're being
hard on tech tech is also something that
can be very useful valuable in our lives
are there ways that you would recommend
using technology I don't know to learn
something new to improve yourself in
2020 yeah absolutely there's a lot of
good that tech can do so one of the ways
that you can keep your mind fresh in
2020 is by learning something new the
older we get the more we become
specialized and experts and one specific
thing so it really helps our brains if
we learn new things and you can do that
through various online websites that
offer courses one of them that I like is
master class they bring in celebrities
and experts you can learn comedy acting
singing cooking anything you want to
become an expert in you can do and it's
pretty inexpensive at fifteen dollars a
month not bad although I would recommend
after you watch the comedy or the acting
or the cooking class online that you
actually go out in the real world and
try yeah you got to do it in the end to
fir Sharon thank you very much
you